el líder del golpe de estado en mali
encabeza ahora el gobierno de transición
el coronel así migoya el líder del golpe
de estado de agosto de 2020 que en su
momento de puso el presidente ibrahim
bubacar keita se convirtió este viernes
en presidente
estamos en un punto crucial de la
historia
[Música]
debemos dejar nuestras diferencias a un
lado para reconstruir mal
su ascenso de la vicepresidencia a la
presidencia lo válido la corte
constitucional maliense que de este modo
establece un marco legal al nuevo golpe
que el mismo coronel así migoya ejecutó
a principios de semana el pasado lunes
el presidente y el primer ministro
transitorios back down y moctar one
fueron arrestados por el ejército ambos
mandatarios presentaron su supuesta
dimisión al mismo momento y fueron
liberados el jueves el coronel guaita
justificó los ceses aludiendo que los
mandatarios sustituyeron a los ministros
de defensa y seguridad sin consultarle a
pesar de que estas áreas dependan de
vicepresidencia cartera que goitia
ostentaba ahora que goite asume la
presidencia propone como reemplazo la
vicepresidencia a un miembro del m5 rcp
para estabilizar el peso del poder
el m5 efe rp está en estrecho contacto
con las autoridades de la transición
para asegurar su cumplimiento
llegado el caso se implicará de lleno
para garantizarla
una inestabilidad política que es
señalada por la comunidad internacional
en especial por la unión europea que ha
anunciado sanciones
estamos preocupados por este golpe de
estado dentro del golpe de estado que
supone una interrupción en un proceso
transitorio que era muy positivo el
nuevo presidente el coronel goitá lideró
el golpe de estado hace nueve meses con
la promesa de convocar elecciones
democráticas a lo largo de 2022